all right let's hear from some folks in
the audience via the david pakman show
discord which you can find at
davidpakman.com
discord let's start today with uh
james from new york is that is this is
this james md
from new york are you a doctor
oh boy james oh yeah
how are you good how are you i'm doing
well
yeah um so i called in before sort of
asking about why it seems like this
whole government seems to be missing the
force for the trees i thought you gave a
great answer
um i have a question for you about
it seems like biden is just sort of
entering the game
trying to play let's be friends with
everybody let's
show unity almost like letting the
republicans
sort of like undercut his positions you
know give less for covid
not do basically the best for the
american you know
person and why doesn't biden just ram
all these things down their throats to
basically get the general public to be
like wow
my health insurance is better my
food is better and cheaper i actually
did get money
under biden why does he seem to want to
compromise on all this stuff to pretend
like there's unity
when the republicans are in power they
put all the supreme court justices on
and say
tough break you lost the election well i
think we still need a little more time
to know which path he's taking
you're completely right that joe biden
has been talking about unity
he invited republicans to the white
house to meet about the covet bill on
monday night
i am fine with biden talking about unity
and talking to republicans if as you say
in the end he just goes forward and
from what we heard after that monday
meeting from gen saki the white house
press secretary
democrats are just planning to move
ahead with the coveted relief bill as
designed with the 1.9 trillion
i believe it's actually perfect if
biden eventually is just going to say
we're sticking with the 1.9
and it's what democrats go for put these
republicans in a position to actually
vote no on it because that coveted
relief bill is popular with many
republican voters tens of millions of
republican voters
i don't believe call the bluff of the
republicans
i don't believe that every republican is
going to vote against the 1.9 trillion
because they know many of their
constituents want that and they like
that bill
so if what joe biden does is talk about
unity
talk about compromise meet with
republicans and then not go forward with
the 1.9
i will be as pissed as it sounds like
you're going to be if this is all just
biden doing what he said he would do
but then he's still going to stick to
what he wants i'm fine with it we'll
probably know in the next few days which
of the two it's going to be
yeah that's pretty fair i just i would
rather him he could play the
let's have unity together but i just
think he needs to ram
these policies down their throats to
show you know the average american
especially you know it seems like the
biggest class that's voting conservative
these days
is uneducated voters that just to show
them here's the proof in the pudding
here's your money
i got you i gotcha yeah i i don't
disagree let's uh let's see if he does
it james from new york
appreciate the call thank you so much
let's go next
to terence from gloucester terence from
gloucester you're on the air
hi david how's it going uh can you hear
me okay i can hear you fine
uh so i don't know if you remember me
but we spoke a couple of months ago when
i called in under the single letter
pseudonymt
to talk about the decent federalism
project
which was my project on twitter at
decent fed
eroj to advocate for distributing some
power
currently held by the federal government
down to a five-part framework of regions
of the u.s
is i know you take a lot of calls but do
you roughly remember
our conversation or anything we talked
about yes
okay awesome uh so the youtube video on
your channel i think is
called uh should the country be divided
into regions
and i think it's still a worthy video
for people to check out
um but so i remember from our
conversation
uh and correct me if i'm wrong i
understood you as having said
towards the end of our discussion that
you were open at least in principle to a
more
regional approach to governance in the
united states does that sound like a
fair characterization of what you said i
i don't remember exactly but did you
have a question today
yeah so so i guess my big question is
whether you see the events
of like recent uh days recent
months uh as affirming or complicating
the idea of
regionalizing our system of governance
in the way we've discussed before in
terms of
you know the stop the steel the the 17
state attorneys general from the south
and central parts of the country that
um basically wanted to overturn the
election
um as well as sort of the coalition that
uh joe biden built
uh for to win the election i have to
tell you i don't think the events of the
last few months
um to me suggest that uh
regionalization for governance would be
better or worse i don't i don't think it
really strikes me as something to think
about in those terms one way or the
other
okay fair enough and that's that was
really my only question david
all right very good terence from
gloucester great to hear from you
again what if you could read 10
books in just one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently checked out the
book podcast marketing strategy by
daniel rolls
and kieran rogers and so useful so
particularly applicable to what i'm
doing
really recommend it blinkist has books
on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get twenty five percent off a
subscription when you go to blinkist.com
slash pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video